so I'm going to go back to my last
caller for just a second uh before the
break she was asking me where to move
because they're losing their landlords
sold their house one option was I to buy
a trailer that needed rent of renovation
and put it on her her parents a lot or
he was her parents farm the other option
was moving his parents house garage
apartment an hour away two bad options
and I said when you have two bad options
what you need is more options one of the
things I have learned about money
mistakes and for that matter about
business mistakes and for that matter
just about mistakes when you limit
yourself to one or two possible options
because you haven't scratched and clawed
and dug around the problem you know work
the problem hard enough you're almost
always going to make a bad decision and
it's tart you can tell you're doing this
when you make fatalistic statements a
fatalistic statement is an absolute
statement of truth that is simply not
true
in other words stuff like there are no
rental properties at all in this town
you know that's a stupid but statement
okay that's just not true there's only
one school my child can go to know
there's a school on dadgum every corner
what about there's just one church
there's this one girl like a date I
can't date her so that's it the one got
away that's it I'm going to be a monk
what I mean really because this is
fatalism it act like there was one shot
or two shots at something and all that
is is you're working yourself up to
about to make a bad choice is what
you're doing let me let me help you with
this when you're negotiating or when you
are making a decision either one the
same principle applies he with the most
choices most options wins if you
I've had this happen with small business
people I'm coaching them they're going
you know we launched our lease and the
guy's gonna he's going to double I rent
it's gonna double I rent well move okay
a model well you have to move because
you're gonna go bankrupt okay move we've
got a business if we move your business
if you stay we can see the assumption
there is that I have to the only place
on the whole freaking planet that this
business can operate is that particular
piece of square footage Oh give me a
break we've been there 30 years now I
get it that it's hard to emotionally
tear yourself away from that I get that
but there's lots of places to operate
and oh by the way change sometimes is a
positive thing hello
so if you have options in front of you
that aren't really good get more options
keep scratching keep keep working the
problem work the problem work the
problem work throw them I'll give you an
example this in business I've had young
leaders come to me and they go you know
we've got this position to fill and
we've narrowed it down to three people
that were interviewing and really just
you know it's the lesser of which evil I
mean none of them are great but this is
the one that's the that sucks the least
you know I'm going to you can't hire any
of those ah I'm so tired of interview I
don't care you have found the positions
you found the person for the position
yet you're going to take the one that
sucks the least and expect excellence in
your business give me a break man no way
no way and I run the leader out of my
office and say you're not allowed to
hire any of those three people you have
to go do the work work the problem work
the problem and let me just tell you
I've I noticed 30 years you would not
believe the number of times at two weeks
later the very person that God had
designed since time began for that
position shows up oh we get the right
perfect person to come on board and we
would have missed them if we'd settled
for the one that sucks the least you
know you bank a bad decision when you
limit your options the number of times
I've almost moved our business to a
certain place and then I looked at
one or two more things and there it was
and I almost settled
you almost settle for barely good enough
are not quite good enough and then
excellent shows up because you keep
working the problem options options
options options options options options
and more options get more figure out
there's more than one way to skin a cat
there's a lot of different ways to get
this done we got a salt work the problem
work the problem work the problem work
the problem you if you haven't found
something that makes you smile when you
think about doing that in that situation
you're making a bad decision you're
about to cause yourself a problem and
people make financial decisions all the
time that are multi $10,000 mistakes
they buy the wrong house they buy the
wrong car they take the wrong vacation
they cuz they settle don't settle
you only get unreasonable levels of
excellence when you're unreasonable
that's tweetable you only get
unreasonable levels of excellence when
you're unreasonable work the problem
work the problem hard get more options
the more options you have the more power
you have in making the decision oh and
by the way the better you can negotiate
if you're not married to a certain
purchase you can negotiate harder on
that purchase but if you have to have it
it's the only one on the planet only
ones the buyer knew you're getting ready
gets screwed it's coming you're getting
ready to get screwed you're about to
view and you did to yourself with your
fatalistic thinking don't get locked in
like there's only one way to do
something and that drama kicks in in
your voice I've done it a thousand times
and I've made this mistake and it always
leaves a bump on my head and my wallets
a little lighter I pay some stupid tax
every time I violate this but when I for
myself to not accept mediocre as my
standard and I go let's work the problem
some more I still I don't know how we're
going to do it I don't know where that
lady's going to live but a garage
apartment on our way doesn't sound fun
and a renovated trailer on Betty's land
really doesn't sound fun so maybe
there's another place to live than those
two what do you think work the problem
work the problem work thrum I'm not
picking on her it's just a great example
of how we all of our brains do this and
if we're not careful we get on that
track and we go it's the only thing I
get it's not the only thing you can do
drama queen stop it I do it I get a
drama queen mode and you do it and she
did it and we can't do that we it causes
you to make dumb butt decisions or to
rationalize a decision you wanted to
make because you feel trapped the number
of times I've had people call me over 25
years of doing this show and they say
stupid but stuff like this listen to
this one I was forced to buy a car they
had a gun were you forced we're forced
to buy a car yeah I totaled my car you
totaled a $15,000 car is that why you
bought a $35,000 car I'm so confused
you were not forced yeah but we are
we've outgrown our car we have too many
children my $6,000 car will not work
anymore so get us $6,000 and the see
this is what we do in it we get all
trapped and that's our method of
rationalizing stupid crap that we're
going to redo like going to car payments
right or rent the wrong building or move
to the wrong property or buy a house
while we're still in baby step two and
we're broke
or whatever it is we're rationalizing
because we're trying to present the case
that we are trapped you are not trapped
you just need more options options are
power when you're making decisions hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]